So now does Islam oppress women or not?
>> I mean I see the way you're trying no
>> a salesman is always good at selling.
>> So based on that does Islam put a man in
check?
>> Yeah.
>> Does Islam oppress women?
>> No.
>> Okay. So do you see what I'm saying?
Sister
Islam is raising funds to establish a
masid and community center in Norway and
they urgently need your support. This
donation will be a for you because every
person that comes a step closer to Allah
through your donation, you will be
reaping the reward. Click the link and
donate what you can.
>> Your family is an atheist.
>> No, my dad's atheist.
>> And your mother?
>> My mom is she's not religious. She
believes in God, but she's not. Yeah.
So, you you you can't look you can't
follow your forefathers cuz that's blind
following. Like myself, if I was to
follow my dad, I would have been an
atheist. Look into it yourself. There's
nothing no harm in reading the Quran. So
read it and see for yourself. You got
nothing to lose. You got a free copy.
>> Yeah. But yeah, but would you um freely
fre really do this for other religions?
>> Yeah. Before before I came to
>> be interested in looking at other
religions.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, not 100%. Before I came
to Islam, I read the Bible. I read the
Old Testament, Judaism. I read Islam. I
looked a bit into seeikism. I looked a
bit of Hinduism. So to me,
>> one your favorite one.
>> Yes. Not not my favorite one. What the
truth is. I don't pick based on my
desires. I don't pick which one suits my
agenda. If it suits my agenda, I will
never accept Islam cuz Islam is it can
be difficult. So to me, whatever is the
truth and the truth was Islam because
the Quran hasn't been changed. He
believes in one god. Even some of your
guru like one of your gurus, he was he
went to I think if he went to Mecca or
something like that. So you see, so
there's truths in that as well. So what
I'm saying is um that if we follow the
truth, we should just look into it,
whatever it is. So I'm saying read the
Quran.
>> What's the physical evidence? No one
see.
>> Okay. So we say you a seek you believe
in god right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Has anyone seen your god?
>> Guruana our god is the book the guru.
>> Okay. No one second. No that's that's
that's one that's one of the gurus.
>> But you believe in god. You don't
believe guru is a god.
>> I don't know that much. But
>> okay but as far as I know you don't
believe the gurus are god. You believe
good. And one of the teachers is the
book.
>> Good. So we say there has to be a
creator that send those gurus if you
believe in that. Okay. So what we say is
you haven't seen that. I haven't seen
it. But I believe in it. Why? For
example, your jacket. You have a jacket,
correct?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Is your jacket made somewhere?
>> Where?
>> The manufacturers.
>> Good. Did you go and see them?
>> No.
>> So, how do you know it was made?
>> Because it's a physical item. It has to
have been made.
>> Good. Perfect. Are you physical?
>> Yeah.
>> So, it should be made.
>> But do you not think there's Adam and
Eve, there's a big bang, there's Jesus.
Jesus is God, but God is the son of No.
That's Christians. We're not Christians.
We're Muslims. do not think there's so
much uh like blurred lines within
religion and who God is in every
religion.
>> No, because if you look at all
religions, even in the Bible, for
example, is it says God is one.
>> Yes. The only one true God is the
father. We as
>> we believe that everyone all gods are
the same, but we just see in a different
way.
>> No, we believe we believe that there is
one God. Every religion believes there's
one God. What they do is that the issue
they fall into is that they start saying
Jesus is God or the Hindus say there are
millions of God. So they all ultimately
believe in one source of power but
sometimes they fall into what we call as
shik which is associating partners. We
say Islam is pure montheism that God is
one. He's not a man or a woman. There is
nothing like him and he's worthy of
worship.
>> Do you not think Islam is degraded to
women?
>> No. How women are how women
>> how old he by the way?
>> Uh 20.
>> Okay. Yeah. So would you
>> that you can have five wives?
>> Four wives.
>> Got four wives. That's deemed
acceptable. How can you tell me why it's
not acceptable?
>> Because you're meant to provide for one
person, show your love to one person.
How can you give your all to four
different people and have kids with four
different people?
>> You you you can like even for example,
you will agree that your four fathers,
your great-grandparents, etc. may have
had more than one wife. Now why
>> would you think acceptable? For example,
in Dubai is very common. There's four
houses next door to each other that are
completely identical.
>> So, so tell me sister, which one is
better? Let me give you a scenario. We
believe. Do you accept men and women are
created differently?
>> Yes.
>> Good. Do you accept that they have
different requirements?
>> Do you agree that when a woman a woman
is more vulnerable than a man in the in
the sense physically?
>> Okay. Good. I believe women are
psychologically and mentally more
stronger than men.
>> Why?
>> I believe they're created like that.
Like we as men, we cannot cuz you guys
can express your feelings. You can cry
about it. If I cry next to my friends,
they'll laugh at me.
>> So there's a stigma on me. You guys can
go speak more as as as psychologist.
Women speak more than men. Yes. That's
your way of uh you know emotions good
perfect when you cry around your friends
none of them will come and say why is
she crying that's normal cuz they all
cry they all cry together so what we say
is this the greatest inequality is to
treat unequal things equally
the greatest inequality is to treat
unequal so me and you are unequals
>> you can't treat us the same because
we're not
>> No no no no no no would you say that if
a man is holding a knife would you
expect me to protect you or let you
fight
>> uh
I don't expect a man to do anything for
me. I don't believe that a man has to do
it for me. He has to.
>> But you think they have
>> he has to. If you're here and so what
about my husband leaves me? Yeah. And
I'm financially financially dependent on
my husband because since I married him,
I don't work. I He leaves me. I I would
feel I have to stay in that marriage
because if I leave that marriage, I'm
left with nothing.
>> And Islam has a solution for you.
>> No, you can't always go back to your
parents. Huh? No. Accept. Islam has a
solution for you. Let's talk about it.
Firstly, let's look let's talk about
polygamy. In polygamy, Allah, God
Almighty knows how he's created a man. A
man is a visual creature and a man has a
man's sexual desires are far greater
than a woman. There's studies that show
this. There is no comparison. Now, what
that means the following in Islam, it
says the following. A man, we're not
told that every Muslim man has to have
more than one wife. No. However, if a
man has the capabilities of looking
after more than one wife, he is not
allowed to have a girlfriend. He's not
allowed to have a mistress. He's not
allowed to have a side chick. Why?
Because these individuals that he has on
the side, he's with them for what? I
don't go into detail. Yeah. Okay.
Someone there. So, Islam says if you
want to do it, you do it honorably. How?
Did you marry your first wife? Yes. Did
you speak to her father? Yes. Did you
give her a dowy? Do you know what a
diary is? Good. You get a diary. Do you
have a house for her? Good. Do you
provide for her? Yes. We don't believe
in 50/50 in Islam. The man covers
everything. Good. He's a full-time
bodyguard and if he's a full-time
provider and protector. Good. If you
want another woman, you cannot abuse
another woman. What does a lot of mus
non-Muslim men do? Yes. They go behind
their wife's back. Good. Islam says no.
Cuz what you're doing is degrading
another woman for one thing. One sec.
One sec. So, sorry. So, Islam says if
you're going to do it, you do it the
right way. So polygamy has come to
protect the rights of all women so that
men don't have an easy route by saying
I'll buy a Louis Vuitton bag, take her
out for dinner, get what I want, throw
her like she's a bin. Islam says a woman
is not a bin. She's not a trash. She's a
human being. You cannot use and abuse a
woman. So that's why when a man is told
you have to marry her, a man, you know
what a man thinks? Oh my gosh, I have to
marry her, give diary to her, speak to
her, dad, that's wrong. I don't want to
do it. What does it do? It protects the
woman. If he wants to do that, what does
it do? He honors the other woman with a
marriage. He gives a dowy. So it's
equal. Which one is better? Use an abuse
or honor through marriage.
>> Honorary. That's one reason. So when it
came to um if financially you depend on
your husband, good. You know what?
Remember the diary I talked about that's
your security. So when you marry a man
Islamically, when he gives you that
dowy, if anything go wrong between you
two, that money is something that you
depend on.
>> Okay, fine. But say for example,
that's that's great. You might come from
a rich family. So the man is lucky. He's
he's prov
9 to5. If you say to him, I want £75,000
in a diary. He has to work and pay you
that.
>> Okay? 75,000 is not enough for a woman
to be to be dependent on when they leave
their husband.
>> You know what men do these days? They
dead beat dads. You know what they do?
They don't job seek allowance
>> and they don't they they you know. So
Islam says no. Number one, financially.
Number two, your family male members
will keep you in check. If he wrongs
you, he has to deal with them. So what
I'm saying is those things are in place
to protect you. If you are pregnant,
Allah says in the Quran, if you do a
divorce, he has to look provide and the
child until the suckling period. Good.
So Islam gives a practical solution to
these problems. In that meantime, when
you have that 7 and 1 half hours or
whatever it is, it will keep you going
until you will find someone else to
marry. And then guess what? He's your
pro provider. Now if you can't then it's
your dad. If not your dad it's your
brother. If not your brother it's your
uncle. So you're always under the
protection of men.
>> Do you understand?
>> You know Muslim men would abuse the fact
that they can have your four wives. As
much as you say yeah you know they honor
they but a fact of humans they'll abuse
what they're given you know then there's
a punishment for that. You're given like
an inch you take a mile
>> then there's a punishment for that. And
guess why? That's the reason why Allah
has protocols in place. For example, if
a Muslim man, let's say you're a Muslim
woman and he wants to take you as a
second wife. You're going to say to him,
listen, number one, I need to speak to
my dad. Number two, I don't do no
dating. There is no we're going to go on
a date. So sorry, I'm not about that
life. Number three, you have to pay me
diary. Number four, where am I staying?
Number five, are you paying for the
bills? No. Bye-bye. You've got protocols
in place to protect your heart.
>> And when you can't date, how you
>> when you marry someone, you marry them
for life with no intention of divorcing
unless something happens.
>> No. Well, yes. Everyone goes into a
marriage without a divorce. But divorce
happens. It's normal. In Islam, divorce
is not shunned.
>> Okay? You can't date the person. You
can't get to know them. How?
>> No, you can get to know them.
>> But but you need a father present.
>> No. No. You do. You do. When seekism,
it's it's a similar thing. You do it.
One second. Are you telling me in
seekism you can get to know a man and
your dad you say, "Okay, go on a date."
>> No, no, no. But for in Islam, dating is
forbidden.
>> No, no, no. There's halal. We don't call
it dating. Yeah,
>> there is a process of you getting to
know someone. For example, a Muslim man
can get to know a Muslim woman with the
permission of his father with a third
person there. Not exactly there. For
example, you want to go out and eat.
He's just there. You guys are walking
just behind you. You do your thing. You
get to know each other, but he will
never leave you guys alone. Why?
>> Keep an eye on the man.
>> Yes. Why? Because Islam understands that
the man has a power over you. Look how
Islam protects women. Cuz you spoke
about that. Yeah. There's a
misconception. Do you agree that a man
can overpower you physically?
>> Yeah.
>> He can do other stuff as well. Yeah.
>> Good. He can manipulate you.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Good. So, Islam says your brother
is there just in case he tries that. So,
and a man knows a man. So, if I am bad
intentions with a woman, if her
brother's there, what would I be
thinking?
>> You know that the woman's got security,
she's got a backup, I can't try nothing.
>> You see what Islam does is Islam is
pragmatic. What it does is it says this
man might break your heart. And yeah, so
Islam says your guardian is the male
members, not the female members, the
male members cuz a man knows a man.
Yeah. Okay. That's the reason why he's
protecting you and to s and say, "Hold
on a second. I know I'm a man. I know a
man. I can say, you know what? I don't
like him. There's something about I
don't like." Do you get it? So Islam has
got the man to protect you from the
moment. Look, if you think about it,
from the moment the woman's born, a man
is always there to protect them. Why?
Because Allah has understood that.
That's why as a mother, you are the
nurturing center when it comes to your
baby. Do you get it? Do you not love the
fact that your baby relies on you?
Argument sake. If you had a child, yeah,
good. We as men, we love the fact that
our women rely on us. We see them as our
babies. Do you get it? Now, are there
Muslim men that do bad stuff? 100%.
There are Muslim men that do terrible
stuff and they should be ashamed of
theirel. Yes. Because Islam has category
told them how to treat women. And the
prophet peace be upon him's last sermon
was what? That be good to women. Yes.
And before the feminists were fighting
for their rights here, for example, the
right to work, the right to own
property, the right to not take the
husband's surname. Yes. The right one.
Yeah. The right to um own property, the
right to work, the right to choose who
you want to marry. Do you know Islam
gave this to the woman 1400 years ago?
>> Yeah. back in like Afghanistan or
whatever the countries are, the women
are so suppressed. They can't watch they
can't talk. They can't show their face.
They can't
like get pregnant.
>> No, no, no. See, see this is very
interesting. Why is pregnancy just
that's it? Why have we reduced something
so magnificent to a just it?
>> Because they can't work. Why do they
need to work? Their husband is going to
work.
>> Exactly. What's the leave the house? The
husband's going to do
>> you know do you know how many women in
the west there was a study done of in 30
years of 50,000 men and women. Do you
know women are less happier than before?
They hate the workforce. Women, there
were studies that show that western
women, you know, western women like
Sikhs and Muslim women, they are
becoming more feminist. The feminists
are running away from feminism. You know
why? Cuz they realize what it did to
them. They have been reduced to
obviously she's I don't want to be
careful what I say to a sexual object.
Yeah. Okay. Why? Because they're like,
"Oh, you go and dating." You know what
you've done? You've given the man what
he wants without working for it. Why do
you think men are not getting married
anymore? Why would I get married when I
get exactly what I want without marrying
you, buying a new house, doing all of
this? I get what I want and I say, "You
know what? Thank you. I'm bored." Now,
good. Feminism has destroyed it. So,
that's the reason why you would
understand a woman bonds with her
children. Every woman would want a man
who can work while she's at home with
her kids nurturing the next generation.
You get what I'm trying to say? It's
feminism that's put into women's mind
that oh no, Miss Independent, etc. And
by the way, in Islam, a woman can work.
In Islam, a woman does not have to take
the husband's surname. In Islam, a
woman, you know, in the UK 100 years
ago, if a man had a debt, he can sell
his wife in the market. Yes. Yep. So,
exactly. Islam gave the woman that
right. When the pagan Arabs before Islam
came, they used to bury their girls
alive because they were a woman. And
Allah says in the Quran, that baby on
the day of judgment will ask, "For what
sin did you kill me?" Do you get what
I'm trying to say? Islam has given these
rights for a woman long time ago. The
right to inherit. The right to choose
who you want to marry. The right to not
take your husband's surname. You get it?
The right to divorce. In Islam, you can
in Judaism. You can't divorce your
husband. In Christianity, there is no
divorce. Why do you think Henry the A
was killing his wives?
>> How many G and white people divorce
their divorce their husbands? Now,
there's so many how many white people
divorced their husband?
>> No, no, no, no. That's fine. But what
I'm saying is there is no order in that
house because in that house there is no
leader hierarchy. The man is the leader
of the house. I believe the man is the
leader of the house. He has the last
say.
>> Okay. So woman you agree in that?
>> Yeah. So no I don't believe my man has
the last say in a relationship.
>> Go on what basis? One second. On what
basis? On what basis do you say that the
man is not do you accept that your
husband is the leader of the house?
>> So if I disagree with something or I
want to do something he tells me
straight no I have to I have to obey. No
you can't go to work. I say yes I won't.
>> Yes and no. Let me tell you how. For
example, a man we believe in Islam has
the right to say, for example, a Muslim
woman can tell her Muslim husband,
you're not allowed to have female
friends. Clear cut. And that's true. A
woman has a right to tell her husband,
you have to pay for everything.
>> 100%. She will tell him.
>> That's a level of power.
>> No. No. Okay. But why is there a why why
is that power? We say the man has
responsibility, not a perk. It's not a
perk. It's a responsibility. Do you
think it's easy that when I'm walking
down the road with my wife and a man
pulls a knife and I need to put my life
on the line? Why does a sheep go put her
life on the line?
>> Yeah.
>> Why does she become misindependent and
feminist? You go and die, please, for
us. I'll look after the kids. Yeah. I'll
make biryani at home. Do you get what
I'm saying?
>> We die. And guess what? When I die,
what's she going to go and get married
again?
>> Do you believe in remaring? So say I
don't know you, you know, you have a bad
relationship,
>> you have a bad relationship and is a
divorce and there's a
>> said in Islam, in Islam, a woman, a
woman can marry 10 times. No one can say
nothing to halal.
>> And then that husband has to treat the
wife's kids like it's his own.
>> Say that again.
>> That husband, the new husband has to
treat the wife's old kids like they're
his own.
>> Of course, you can't oppress them. So
much so, Islam even says when they reach
a certain age, the kids should go to the
father. Praise the Lord Jesus.
>> They should have stayed with the mother
>> in a certain age. You know why? Because
Islam looks at the wellbeing. You know,
sometimes when a big not get a choice.
>> Let me tell you something kind of you
know essay.
>> You know what I'm saying? Yeah. Okay.
Good. Usually happens with stepfathers.
>> That's why Islam has a protocol in place
that after a certain age they go to the
father cuz the money the woman can be
easily manipulated by the the stories
happen.
>> Women can be easily manipulated. that
women can, but that doesn't mean every
woman can.
>> I never said that. I'm saying Islam has
a solution for everyone. Exceptions
don't make the rule. We deal with the
situation where we can't say, "Oh, yeah,
for example, drink driving." Some might
say, "You know what? Drink drivers are
safe, but there might be one that kills
four people." Ban all. Islam doesn't
deal with, "Oh, but there might be one
that isn't." I don't care if the if if
one person can kill, we ban all. Good.
So, do you see now does So, now does
Islam oppress women or not?
I mean, I see the way you're trying. No,
no, no.
>> A salesman is always good at selling.
>> Good. Okay. Tell me what I said is a
lie.
Tell me. Okay. One second. Either what
I'm saying is the truth or I've just
done magic on you. Hey, I done this.
Look. Hello. Listen to what I'm saying.
>> You guys believe in jeans and all that.
So,
>> so what's got to do with women's rights?
>> No, it doesn't. But you you
>> I'm saying to you what from what I've
told you sister from what I've told you
are women oppressed in Islam or not?
>> Yeah.
>> So women are oppressed in Islam.
>> They can't show their hair.
>> So one second. One second. So after wife
>> they can't show their body because
no no women. No. Thank you. Again that's
an assumption. Nowhere in Islam does it
say dress up cuz men can't control the
self.
>> So so why so why they can't show their
body?
>> Thank you. Good. Okay. Good. Ask. Okay.
You can ask me. Okay. Good. Ask me.
Okay. Good. Number one, as a seek,
>> what do you do when you go to your um
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. We don't wear
>> disrespectful clothes. What do you wear?
Why is it disrespectful?
>> Okay. I wouldn't I wouldn't go in in
like shorts.
>> No, go in a mini skirt. Why not?
>> What would What would they say to you?
What would you If there's a What do you
call the thing?
>> Because it's just like there's a level
of appropriateness. But why?
>> Why isn't appropriate? That's
misogynistic. Go and I think you should
go to argument sake in a bikini.
>> What would happen?
>> Just get told to leave.
>> Why?
>> But I can walk. There's no rule in my
religion that I can't walk around the
streets and and not dress.
>> One second. One second. So let me get
this right. You have modesty in the So
what's
>> your level of modest? Our level of
modest.
>> No, no, no. Who? Okay, good. So who
decides? For example, the woman who
walks here half naked and the seek woman
and the Muslim woman, which one is the
correct one? Which one is modest?
>> Just cuz you're modest isn't always
correct. You could be modest, but you
can still commit sin.
>> Committing sins and being modest are two
separate things. A woman can wear the
hijab and can go and sleep around, but
she still has to wear the hijab. Two
wrongs don't make her right.
>> Look, she's so holy compared to the
other Muslim next to her that's got a
full face of makeup.
>> We don't judge a woman by her internal
affairs. If a woman wears a mini skirt,
we say that that is a wrong dress. But
nobody can say she's she's a woman who
sleeps around.
>> So there's 10 men. Yeah. One in a bura,
one in a mini skirt. Yeah.
>> 10 men or 10 women?
>> 10 10 men in a line. And in front is a
woman woman in a burka. Woman in a in a
mini dress.
>> Yeah.
>> Who do you want to marry? No one's going
to say they want to marry a woman in a
mini.
>> No, no, no. One sec. Okay.
>> Cuz they're immediately judged.
>> No, no, no, no. But of course you're
going to judge someone from what's
apparent. If you Okay. If you're walking
down here,
>> you just told me you never judge anyone.
>> No, no, no. Mr. Do carefully. We do not
judge a person's internal affair. If a
woman dress up in a mini skirt, I will
say her dress is immodest. I can see and
I can judge. However, I cannot say she
probably sleeps around. No, just because
she wears a mini skirt doesn't mean
that. If I see a woman in a go, wow,
she's wife immaterial. Okay. How do you
know she doesn't sleep around? So, you
judge from the apparent but you cannot
make judgment internally. If I see a man
with an earring and tattoos, I can't say
he's probably a robber. No, he's wearing
earring which is haram. He's got tattoos
which is haram. But you cannot make a
judgment about his personal affairs and
say he's probably an armed robber or a
gangster. No, he's not. So what I'm
saying is this sister who decides
>> haram.
>> Yes. For a man to wear not a woman.
>> Why not a woman?
>> Cuz for a woman it's adorn. That's fine.
A woman can wear gold. A man can't wear
gold.
>> No. No. But what I'm saying is you know
like you can't have tattoos because
you're changing what God gave you. But
you're changing.
>> No. Earrings is not it's permissible.
>> Earrings. No, you're not. You're not cuz
it's No, you're not. You can't. For a
woman, it's permissible. Not for a man.
>> Why?
>> Cuz God said so.
>> But but was there earrings and was there
tattoos and everything like that?
>> Yeah. Yeah. It was it was there. It was
there. It was there. But what I'm saying
is this. When it comes to modesty, why
for example women wearing like Let me
ask you a question. Why do you not cover
your hair?
>> I don't need to. I don't care who looks
at my hair.
>> It's not about who looks. I'm saying as
a seek woman, what are you told to do?
>> To not cut your hair.
>> Not to cover your hair.
>> Not to cut it.
>> Not to cut it. Okay. Do you cut your
hair?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Why did you cut your hair?
because I don't like long hair.
>> Okay, good. All right,
>> that's fine. What I'm saying is this.
>> I believe that everyone is influenced
one way or another. Do you genuinely
believe girls who wear mini skirts will
wear it cuz they want to?
>> What what you're saying is that they
wear it because what?
>> They're coerced to
>> by
>> the society.
>> Okay. But
>> indirectly, let me tell you something.
Do you not think that as a woman you
have pressures on you to look beautiful?
>> Yeah.
>> Do you not think that these pressures of
makeup, the beauty industry, the
opposite gender, the billboards,
Instagram, Tik Tok, Netflix. Do you
think
>> Hi.
>> Hello. How are you?
>> Good, thanks.
>> Fantastic. We're just talking about
religion and you know
>> I'm an atheist.
>> There's God. Do you want a Quran? Free
Quran.
>> I'm an atheist. No, thank you.
>> Okay, that's fine. Thank you very much.
That was interesting. So do you think
that there is not external factors that
influence men and women to how to dress
up?
>> Yeah, I don't feel men have as much and
I think women have more.
>> Good. So women have more pressure on
them of the way they look, the way they
dress. So are you telling me a woman
wakes up in the morning and says I can't
wait to spend 2 and 1 half hours doing
my makeup?
No. You know there was a study done, you
know, 5 years ago when COVID happened,
everyone had to wear masks. Do you know
they noticed women were carrying on
wearing the masks when masks were not
obligatory anymore? And do you know why
they said? cuz they said I can just wear
my mask and not wear makeup.
Which means what? They are coerced
subconsciously to dress up like this.
Why does most of the women wear minis
curs and show their cleavage? Why is it
systematically the same to other?
>> Now let me ask you a question. Is that
freedom that you are dressing in a way
in a freezing cold?
>> It's still sister. No, that's what I'm
saying 100%. I'm saying there's coercion
done indirectly. Have you heard of uh
manufacturing consent?
>> Good. Manufacturing consent is this.
It's me making you say yes by telling
you if this and that and this and that.
You're like, "Oh, okay. Now, usually you
say no." But if I break it down, I'm
manufacturing. Good. Which is called
brainwashing, manipulation. Yes. Good.
So, what Islam does is this. Islam says,
"Allah, God Almighty tells me how to
dress. I grow a beard cuz Allah told me
to. I wake up for prayer five times a
day cuz God told me to." Now you have
two options sister. A Muslim has two
options. A Muslim woman. You either
follow what God told you and dress up
how God told you from day dot Adam or
you come and try to do fashion and
fashion changes. Today is a mini skirt.
Tomorrow is a bikini. The other day wear
a uh uh paint on you. So good. So what
I'm saying is this. This is subjugation
sexually objectification of women. Men
do not see you as human when you dress
up inappropriately. That is a reality.
So Islam deals with the reality. Not La
La Land. We're in Disney World. Yes. It
doesn't work like that. Islam deals with
the reality. What Islam says is this.
When you cover yourself up, I'm talking
to you. I'm not looking anywhere else,
sir. Do you get it? And guess what? You
know, men can fall in love the wrong
way.
>> Yeah. And guess what happens when men
fall in love the wrong way? They might
look and say, "You know what? I'm not
really into that girl, but she has got a
really nice, so I'm just going to
pretend, get a white one, and tell her
bye-bye."
Isn't that dehumanization? Yeah. At the
end of the day, women can do the same.
>> How the stigma on men that men use and
abuse women are hypergamous by nature.
They do the same by looking at a man.
He's tall. He's handsome. He's rich. D.
If every man had their bank balance on
their head, it's as good as a woman
wearing inappropriately cuz that
attracts them. For a woman, when she
sees the bank, if everyone had their
bank balance in their head, trust me, a
lot of women, you know what a woman
would be doing? They would say, "I wish
I never saw that." A woman who's with a
man who's not earning enough looks at
another man goes, "Oh my gosh, I can be
with him." What do you think it does
when you are married and you're walking
and there's so many women dressed up in
a properly and your husband, of course,
we are told, Allah says to us in the
Quran, tell the believing men to always
gays. Don't look.
>> No matter if she's a Muslim woman or a
Muslim woman, don't look at
inappropriate things. Do you get what
I'm trying to say? Why? Cuz Islam says
>> that's inappropriate in the first place.
>> In the Quran, Allah tells us that a man
and a woman should lower their gates,
especially men, cuz we men are visual
creatures. You women are emotional
creatures. Yes. You fall for what you
hear. Yes. Okay. So, uh with us, we fall
for what we see. Do you get it? That's
the reason why women wear makeup and men
lie. Do you get what I'm trying to say?
So, what we're saying is this, sister,
Allah has put those in place. So, when a
woman wears an abaya, I can't see her
body shape. I can't see her. Her hair is
a beauty. So, I'm judging her based on
what? Her intellect.
She's a human being. She's Do you get
what I'm trying to say? Now, when a
woman has her breasts out, a man is
going to be like, "My attention is keep
going somewhere else because he's
created like that." This doesn't mean
that women have to cover up cuz men
can't control theel. Both men and women
have to do their bit. Men should lower
their gaze and a woman should cover up
so they both doing what they need to do.
Number two, there should be no
billboards of half naked women doing an
advertisement for a chocolate bar. What
has a chocolate bar got to do with a
half naked woman? It's more attractive.
>> What's more attractive?
>> You'll get drawn to it.
>> Good. So, let me ask you a question.
>> Which one has your best interest?
Feminism that says go and do one night
whatever liberalist. Islam that says no,
cover up. Do you think men want you
covered up or naked?
>> Men want women naked.
>> Good. What does Islam say? Cover up. For
who? For your own good. If Islam was
against women, it would say, "Yeah,
dress how you want, etc. Get used and
abused." Islam has so many protocols in
place to protect women.
And we see that as oppression.
>> You think if God was trying to look
after women that much, they didn't get
used and abused, God would not have made
men so visual like that?
>> No. Because let me tell you something.
Number one, I'm here. There are women
that are half naked that walk past here.
Yeah. Okay. As a man, my job is to look
away.
>> Yes. I can't come and say, "Oh, they're
dressed up half naked. Let me go them."
No, I'm not.
>> Women have that as their job in their
head.
>> But that's why Allah says in the Quran,
this is why you need the Quran to
educate men how to behave like men. What
does the industry do today? You watch
things for example,
you know, pornography, pornography.
Okay? And what does that do? That
dehumanizes woman further. And then
you've got a man who's with his wife
being intimate, but he's not content.
You know why? Cuz he's watching
something else. He's watching something
that is not real. That's why Allah says,
"Lower your gaze. Don't sexually
objectify women." Do you get what I'm
trying to say? So based on that, does
Islam put a man in check?
>> Yeah. Does Islam oppress women?
>> No.
>> Okay. So, do you see what I'm saying,
sister? Islam has come to honor and
respect you. Are there Muslim men out
there who do crazy stuff? Yes. I deal
with I know about it. Do you get what
I'm trying to say? But Allah has put
this in place. If you stick to this
thing, your heart will not be broken. Do
you get it? If you stick to this, you
won't. But if you go with the today's
culture, have dates, boyfriends,
girlfriends, oh, it didn't work out. Oh,
not him, next person. Why are you going
to go through that? Follow the manual
God has sent you. Because that is the
thing. Allah God Almighty created you.
He knows what's best for you. If you
made a product, an Apple iPhone, I'm
going to come to you to find out. I say,
can I put this in the oven? No. In the
water? No. Can I break it? Uh, turn it
into half. No. You're going to say, Ali,
I made it. This it's not for oven. It
can't go under water. Allah has created
us and he knows what's best for us. So,
if you read the Quran, my dear sister,
you will understand the reasons and the
wisdoms behind why Allah has done that.
And then you will understand that we
should have a relationship with him. So
because he's the one that makes your
heartbeat. He's given you your eyes,
your lungs, your kidney. You have
trillions of cells in your body. Without
those cells, you won't be breathing now.
So it says Allah says have a
relationship with him. Thank him for
what he's given you. You know, that's
why I said to you, if you want to read
the Quran, read it. You've got nothing
to lose. I read it 13 years ago, you
know, and I believe the truth is with
Islam.
>> Any Do you have any questions?
>> No, that's it. Thank you.
>> What's your name?
>> A. A. Nice speaking. You know I speak a
lot of seeks and they got a lot of
warrior names.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Like they got really
It's really nice to see you sister. Um
our this our honorable seek sister. May
Allah bless and preserver. I really
appreciate the question that you asked.
Very respectful. Very nice sister. May
Allah bless. Can I give you a Quran to
read?
>> Maybe another day.
>> That's no problem. In our religion it
says there's no compulsion. I can't
force you. I ask Allah to guide you and
yourself. Okay. Nice meeting you. Thank
you very much. Any more questions for
me? That's it. Thank you. Thank you.
Take